there is a news story i'll leave you on
this note today there's a news story out
of metro
headline is
prepare you pull over if you're driving
sit down headline is
ex-soldier exposed her penis and used
wheelie bin as sex toy in public
there it is i'm not making that up
the x the story
is tabloid fodder enough
but
then there's a scandal on top of the
scandal that the tabloid is using her to
refer to him i think it's pretty clear
that it's him ex-soldier is using her
penis is she is she now
is that the case for her no and people
just know
it's bonkers this is how i feel about
squishy republicans i'm all for building
coalitions and i get it a lot of people
are to the left of me but we can maybe
still form coalitions
the transgender thing is
is a line in the sand for me
if you've got a spencer cox or an asa
hutchinson or these squish republican
governors who who cave on the
transgender issue spencer cox now using
preferred pronouns
you're out of my party you're out i
don't be and i think this is true for a
lot of voters not even just republicans
but normal democrats normal people in
the middle they say no if you're gonna
whatever political view has led us to
the point that we're referring to her
penis what whatever it is i don't know
what your your views on immigration and
crime and taxes i don't know whatever
led us to this moment i'm against it my
political ideology is whatever
prevents us from using the pronoun her
with male anatomical features okay
because we just know it you don't need a
phd in political philosophy to know that
that is completely wrong and the voters
know it about what the biden
administration is selling it's why they
don't
have a lot of support right now in that
administration and it's why they're
trying to clamp down on our rights to
express our views because it's the only
way they're going to hold on to any
power glad you like that clip now hold
up
ring the bell
subscribe get those notifications get
past the big tech sensors we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you